i want to get into uh pretty little
liars because that was your first big
hit that was like that was the thing
that kind of
puts you on the on the radar right you
know
how old were you when pretty little liar
started i was very young i
i must have been it was 2009 i got the
call
i remember getting it and i was so young
i just skateboarded i skateboarded to
the audition so you were 20.
it's 20 yeah you skateboarded to the
audition
did you have a fear at all did you go in
there and not give a you know it
was the first
so it's interesting it was like the
first i had gone on so many auditions
for so many different things and i was
doing background work on another
like kind of teen show and i remember
talking to one of the actors on it and
being like dude do you have any pointers
on like how to be an actor like a
working actor
like making money like this doesn't seem
realistic like because i was doing
background work you make like 60 bucks a
day or something
just enough to like buy yourself a
couple meals before
you know and um he was just like
he he looked at me and he's like
honestly just don't give a
and i'm like really that's all it takes
that's the key but what was interesting
is i i cared
so much about i was going into acting
classes
and i still care so much it's
interesting because i
as much as i you you're supposed to not
you're supposed to like
release yourself from the the end result
of your work you're supposed to be
present in it i went in for that
audition and i was just
i just had so much fun i remember having
so much
fun in that audition and um
you know they tell you don't wear
beanies don't cover your eyes i went in
with sunglasses and a beanie on
i did all the things you're not supposed
to do
and there you go that's the key did you
11 years ago was there instagram
we actually our show is one of those it
was probably
the show that kicked off the social
media
frenzy around live tweeting around uh
just social media in general where fans
were essentially steering
the shows uh arcs character
progression i was only supposed to be in
six episodes
my character dies in the book series um
but fans at that time social media had
gotten you know
starting to get a fire under it and fans
were demanding that they didn't kill
tobias kavanaugh which was my character
they're just like do not kill him well
what do you tell the author
what do you tell the guy who writes the
book so no he dies sarah shepard wrote
a book series and it was it's this not
to come back in
full circle here but her universe
ran parallel until it didn't with
marlene king's
version who she developed and was the
showrunner of our
of pll along with oliver goldstick and
they married the two in certain ways and
then
divorced them in other ways and one of
the divorce factors was
my character living and having a
very um strong relationship with one of
the main characters that was
just beautiful